MALE SPEAKER: I'm honored to
introduce Tom Jacobs and John
Del Vecchio, who will be
presenting their book, "What's
Behind the Numbers." I know
these guys as analysts in the
Motley Fool service of
financial analysis.
I have made and saved
substantial money by following
their advice.
So I cannot fail to recommend
that you guys do the same.
John?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Thank you.
TOM JACOBS: Our book title
should be pretty obvious.
And then, this is who we are.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: I'm
John Del Vecchio.
I'm a chartered financial
analyst.
I had the pleasure of working
with Howard Schilit who is a
famed forensic accountant, and
very famous for finding
fraudulent companies that
are publicly traded.
I worked for David Tice who is
the manager of the Prudent
Bear Fund which is the largest
mutual fund in the space
that's short stocks, which
is betting against them.
I'm the co-manager and the
co-founder of the Active Bear
ETF, which is the largest
actively-traded equity ETF in
the market right now.
I work for the Motley Fool under
the Alpha Brand which is
a newsletter that's long and
short at the same time.
It's kind of a hedge fund.
And according to Tom, I'm
a snappy dresser.
I don't write this stuff,
I just read it.
TOM JACOBS: If it weren't
for John and my
non-business partner.
I wouldn't even know
what to do.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Be all dapper
in an Armani suit.
TOM JACOBS: I have a 2000 Men's
Warehouse suit that I
got that's 14 years
old, 13 years old.
John wouldn't let me
go out with that.
Former lawyer.
Graduate of Cornell
and the University
of Chicago Law School.
The reason I mention that is not
to show off pedigrees, but
more to show you that
pedigrees are
irrelevant in investing.
All you need to do is math.
You don't need calculus, which
is good since that was where I
kind of ended my math career.
And some of the allegedly most
pedigreed smart people don't
do well in investing.
I think the life of experience
and learning from mistakes is
more valuable.
However, that's very valuable
when you get in front of a
room of lawyers who are
really, really,
really a tough crowd.
My father got me investing
at 12.
He said, here's $100,
buy something.
I bought Ford instead of
Wrigley, big mistake.
I've been a high school teacher
in Venezuela and
Kenya, all around, a lawyer and
entrepreneur, and today
I'm a portfolio manager of
Motley Fool Special Ops.
What John will talk about
is what he does.
What I talk about
is what I do.
And we both believe that
together, this is the way to
deal with risk.
We're primarily risk managers.
We wrote this because we watched
and lived through
painful losses through
2000, 2002.
John saw this coming and it
wasn't so painful for him.
For me, it was extraordinarily
painful on the long side and
it turned me to value
investing.
And we all know about the zeal
of the newly converted.
I embraced value with the zeal
And catastrophic losses in '08
'09, which really set back the
investing clock for
many people.
And the older that they are, or
were at the time, the more
difficult it's been.
We would like this not to happen
to them or to you.
Three parts today, what doesn't
work, what works, and
then John will give his current
market view, which is
that there are clouds ahead.
What doesn't work?
Dollar-cost averaging is
familiar to most of you.
Google has a 401k plan,
I assume, being a very
forward-thinking company.
And so if you participate in
every paycheck, money comes
out and you direct its
investment in options that the
401k provider offers.
Primarily mutual funds?
You can't buy individual
stocks?
AUDIENCE: Yes, you can.
TOM JACOBS: You can.
AUDIENCE: It's [? Vanguard. ?]
TOM JACOBS: Good.
Excellent.
Excellent, so you can
get into trouble.
No, but I mean, that's a very
good option, particularly for
people who spend a lot of
time working on this.
The problem with dollar-cost
averaging is that what happens
is that people stop making their
payroll deductions or
they move them to cash, and they
lose the benefits of the
automatic averaging
that you get.
The problem with investing for
many people, even in indexes,
is that you inadvertently market
time unless you're
doing it mechanically every
single pay period, averaging
out your purchase
price, right?
The problem is that it
requires discipline.
There was a great study that
Morningstar did where they
looked at the returns of CGM
focus funds Ken Heebner, who
Peter Lynch called one
of the greatest
investors of all time.
Heebner's had incredible
results, but has high
volatility, right?
Up and down high beta
to the averages.
Morningstar found that while
Heebner did extraordinarily
well, his investors did not.
They would sell after a bad year
and then they would buy
after a good year, selling
low and buying high.
This actually is what
most people do.
The other thing that dollar-cost
averaging requires
is a steady income cycle.
And I had the pleasure of
speaking the other night to a
group of people, a number of
whom had been laid off by HP,
and they were actually--
I shouldn't say this--
they were actually
very happy to be gone.
But they had--
they were--
and they had a lot of money.
They got big lump sums
of payouts and so on.
And they said, well, Tom I can't
dollar-cost average.
What do I do?
So it just doesn't
fit most people.
And psychologically, we know
from behavioral finance, this
is very difficult for people.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: This is one
of my favorite charts.
It's about asset allocation
and why it doesn't work.
This is the American Association
of Individual
Investors, which is most of
us in the room here today.
This shows the three time
periods of the highest cash
position and the lowest cash
position and then today.
And we'll get more into the
market view at the end of the
presentation.
But I wanted to highlight
the extremes that occur.
The highest cash position ever
was in March of 2009 at 45%.
If you remember, that's the
exact low of the market.
So, at this point in time,
everybody was slashing their
wrists and running under hot
water when they should have
been buying stock.
And they had 14% bonds and
just 41% in equities.
And now we've been in a massive
44 month move off the
bottom where equities have
well more than doubled.
And if you've picked individual
stocks, in many
cases they're up
1,000% or more.
The lowest cash position of all
time was March of 1998.
And for those you old enough to
remember the internet boom
that ultimately crashed, that
was right around the time when
it was getting into--
TOM JACOBS: Oh, I
remember that.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah, that
was pretty painful.
So everyone was fully invested
here at this time frame.
74% was held in stocks and
just 15% in bonds.
Today, we are at 18.8% cash.
And there's a notion that
there's a lot of cash on the
sidelines in the marketplace,
and that's going to drive the
stock market higher.
I would argue that that's
not going to occur.
You have to remember that
this was during a
once-in-a-generation bubble
period that occurs about once
every 25 years.
It takes a long time to work off
of that until someone is
stupid enough to create
the next big bubble.
And we're at 18.8 and this was
11, so if you cut it in half,
maybe there's 4% more that
could go into equities.
But we also see a lot
more into bonds.
15% bonds here and there's
21% bonds here.
Why is that?
It's because demographics
have changed.
The investors in 1998 have
gotten a lot older.
It's 14 years later.
My mother, for instance,
was a baby boomer.
Her highest earning years
were from 1980 to 1999.
She worked for Bristol-Myers
Squibb.
She had a 401k plan, no college
education, she had
stock options, cash bonuses,
health care.
Most of that stuff has
gone away now.
She was fortunate enough to
retire in 1999, and kind of
rode off into the sunset.
But for the most part, that's
not really happening today for
a lot of people.
So I would argue that this
cash position is probably
about as low as it's going to
get, maybe just a couple
percent lower.
And that's why you need to be
defensive in your portfolio.
But these individual investors
are usually horrible at
allocating capital, and that's
really been the case over the
last 30 or 40 years.
TOM JACOBS: And even the
big asset allocators--
brokers who have their clients
in programs where they'll have
more options, precious metals
and so on, 2008 killed it.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: And we'll
get into that as well.
Active investment managers
who are quote unquote
"professionals" are just
as bad as individuals.
And I'll show you an
even worse chart
when we get to that.
TOM JACOBS: Right.
What investors want is safety.
They want to buy and forget,
and they want inflation
protection.
What they get is volatility,
which scares them into selling
low and buying high.
They buy, forget, and then they
lose, and inflation is
beyond their control.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Today's
winners are tomorrow's losers.
So growth loses over time.
And the stocks from
one generation--
their leaders are generally not
the leaders of the next.
So imagine that we are here in
1979 and I told you that we
were talking about Eastman
Kodak, and Polaroid, and
companies like that that were
Nifty Fifty stocks.
And I said, in 30 years they're
either going to be
bankrupt or bailed out
by the government,
or cut their dividends.
That would sound like blasphemy,
but that's exactly
what happened.
Roll forward to the
internet boom.
You've got Microsoft, Intel,
Cisco, Dell, Hewlett-Packard,
those were kind of the big
horsemen of the internet and
the PC cycle.
That's pretty much been dead
money for the last 14 years.
So if you're a wealth adviser,
and you've got your clients in
those stocks, you probably
got fired.
The bull leaders lose 80% in
the next cycle, that's
research by William O'Neil.
He's the publisher of
"Investor's Business Daily,"
and has been investing in stocks
for about 50 years.
And so you can't just buy a
stock and forget about it.
Times change, the environment
changes, the economy changes,
technology changes, and so
buying for the long term is
actually very dangerous, unless
you're just buying an
index fund and holding that
over a time period.
So what we're going to tell you
to do, or show you how to
do, is avoid the losers before
they become a big torpedo in
your portfolio.
TOM JACOBS: Peter Lynch--
whatever respect we may
have for his books--
did a great deal of damage with
the "buy what you know,"
"buy and hold" because he was
operating in the biggest bull
market that we've ever known
and probably will ever know
when admittedly, he had very
good results, but he had the
wind at this back.
I would be really surprised if
we ever see another bull
market of the length that
we had during--
what, '82 to--
JOHN DEL VECCHIO:
1982 to 2001.
Well, we could argue
about that.
TOM JACOBS: Right, we
could argue about
that, or until today.
Now what I'd like to point out
here is that inflation
protection is entirely
an accident of birth.
Typically we have high inflation
in war time,
followed by high deflation
as the stimulus
is taken out after.
And this is--
World War I was an
example of this.
World War II, where we ended up
with 90% marginal highest
tax rate because we needed to
fund the war and then printed
money to do it.
Now, what we got from the
Bush administration--
and this is not political,
it's just a fact--
was guns and butter.
And as you all remember from
Econ 101, if you have both,
eventually you'll
have inflation.
Under Lyndon Johnson, we had
guns and butter, and
eventually that led
to inflation.
I mean, the idea was, give
people benefits at the same
time that you fund the war,
it's fiscal policy that
usually leads to inflation.
So for example, in the 1970s--
when you add in inflation and so
on-- the average annual S&P
500 return, the real return--
what do I mean there?
All right, let's just say it was
negative every year for 10
years, all right?
And so, if you just happened to
be in that high inflation
period, and that really got bad
in '81 and '82, it was an
absolutely lost decade.
For example, from 1968 to
1982, the Dow was flat.
Absolutely flat.
So I said, OK, it
wasn't so bad.
Maybe I got some dividends.
But the purchasing power--
we argue over this--
dropped 50%.
John says he's seen higher.
So most people don't think
about inflation.
They don't think about real
returns, they think about
nominal returns.
A little known fact is that if
you had been able to keep your
money after the crash of '29--
and of course the problem was
most people couldn't, right--
you lose your job, you have
to spend your savings.
But actually, the purchasing
power of the money was back in
seven years, by 1936.
And what we hear all the time is
it the averages didn't come
back until the early '40s for
the S&P, and the early '50s
for the Dow.
But that's nominal.
In real returns, you had the
same purchasing power by 1936.
And also in the 2000s, you can
see a combination of inflation
and stock market return,
another lost decade.
With inflation, it's just
when you're born.
Stocks do not protect against
inflation, maybe if you had 40
years, 30 years.
But most of us have a 20 to
25 year investing life.
Kids, the mortgage,
the underwater--
OK.
John.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: So one of my
favorite charts and studies is
called the capitalism
distribution.
A lot of people think that
over time, stocks go up.
But as I just mentioned that,
if you invested in Eastman
Kodak in the late '70s you'd
be bankrupt right now.
So most companies in capitalism
actually fail, right?
You have one winner and
lots of losers.
There's one Walmart and there's
40 regional retailers
they don't exist anymore because
Walmart has better
technology, distribution, better
ability to negotiate
with suppliers, and whatnot.
The Blackstar Funds did a really
interesting study that
showed that individual stock
returns from 1983 to 2007--
which was really the largest
secular bull market in
history, and certainly all
of our lifetimes--
most of the stocks were
actually losers.
I'll show you this.
So this is the actual
distribution.
64% of the stocks had a lower
total return than the index
during this time frame.
The index was up 900% and
accounts for 98% of the
liquidity of the US
market, so that's
basically all of the market.
About 34% of the
stocks actually
declined in absolute terms.
25% of the stocks accounted
for 100% of the market's
gains, and about one out
of five actually
went down 75% or more.
So just a very small fraction,
about 6%, dramatically
out-performed the index.
So if you're picking individual
stocks, it's pretty
much about four to one against
you by even finding a company
that over full cycle is going
to beat the index.
So again, if you're dollar-cost
averaging every
month and using the Vanguard
options, it's probably better
to do the index fund than to
pick individual stocks.
The odds are just against you.
And these are the statistics
that I just referenced.
TOM JACOBS: I can't believe
you memorized those.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Well,
I've been saying this
speech a long time.
TOM JACOBS: So the odds are
against investing success.
So what do you do?
Well, you need to avoid
the big loser.
Avoiding a big loser is more
important to your returns than
getting a big winner.
If you lose 50%, you've got to
make 100% just to get back to
where you were.
So most people wake up every day
in the investment business
and they like to go find
the stock that's
going to go up 300%.
That's what gets them excited.
As a short seller, and a
forensic accountant, I like to
find the company that's
going to go down 30%.
Where did that come from?
Well, Tom and I were both born
in upstate New York It's
cloudy about 400 days a
year in Syracuse, so--
TOM JACOBS: In Rochester.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: That's where
you get that mentality.
Is that you, Tom?
Focus not on the winners, but
on what you can lose.
So, if you lose less, you
end up with more.
I think it was Warren Buffett
that said, rule number one is
don't lose, rule number two is
don't forget rule number one.
TOM JACOBS: One thing to say
about that though, of course,
is he's talking about never
have a loss on a stock.
He's talking on a portfolio
basis, don't lose capital
permanently.
And if you're 58 years old and
it's 2008 and you're off 38%,
40%, 45% the clock has reset so
much, that you are pretty
much looking at a permanent
capital loss in terms of your
retirement.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: I think we
said in the book that you're
drinking Natural Light instead
of Dom Perignon, or
something like that.
TOM JACOBS: That
was your line.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: If it was
funny, it was my line.
TOM JACOBS: I can't afford
Dom Perignon, he can.
So here's what we're
here to do.
We've told you everything that
can go wrong and why stuff
doesn't work.
And behavioral finance really
was the breakthrough in this,
when Richard Thaler met Daniel
Kahneman, the 2002 Nobelist in
economics--
who is, by the way, a
sociologist in economics-- and
some of you may have read his
most recent book, I bet.
Thaler was an economist.
I actually knew him when he was
getting his Ph.D. at the
University of Rochester, and I
always dropped that name even
though I met him twice, to bask
in his reflecting glory.
He then went on to great
fame and fortune.
He was doing research one day
and he found out that this
sociologist was doing exactly
what he was doing, which was
trying to find out why the
Chicago School of reactionary
conservative economics
was wrong.
That we don't do rational
things, that we do mental
accounting, that we find
$20 on the floor--
well, that was then-- we find
$100 on the floor and we go,
all right, dinner, drinking,
whatever is the vice.
And they have pretty much
displaced, and this is the
dominant economic theory, and
it's one of the reasons why
what we're going to
talk about works.
People don't behave
rationally.
You get emotional.
People don't dollar-cost average
with discipline.
They change jobs, they
change options.
And the same with asset
allocation.
They become afraid, they
act emotionally.
So what we're not going to do is
just scare you and tell you
how bad everything is, because
we've learned that people
don't behave rationally.
Rather, it's how to take
advantage of that, and so
we'll show you where you're
going to die so
you don't go there.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: So what I
do professionally is I'm a
forensic accountant, which is
two fancy words for reading
numbers and finding companies
that are using accounting in
an aggressive fashion to mask a
deterioration in their business.
Every company has a
bump in the road.
So no company has just a
straight trajectory in growth.
We all experience negative
cycles, where maybe it's
related to the economy, or
a competitor comes in, or
whatever the case may be.
So the question is, is
management open and
honest about it--
I'm talking about to Wall
Street, not just the
employees--
or do they cover it up.
There's a lot of levers that
management or a CFO can pull
to mask a deterioration
in their business.
Most of us are optimistic about
the trajectory of our
business and we think it's a
short term bump in the road.
Unfortunately, the world doesn't
really work that way.
And what turns into a one
quarter bump in the road
sometimes is a major secular
decline, such as like at
Hewlett-Packard for instance,
which we're seeing today.
So the number one predictor
is revenue related.
And I'm going to get into
exactly how to identify that.
And then on Tom's side, it's
buy valuable assets for 50
cents on the dollar and have a
catalyst that's actually going
to be realized, so that value
will be realized.
So avoid the blowups--
that's not my picture.
So the four top earnings quality
predictors, one is so
aggressive revenue
recognition.
The second is aggressive
inventory management.
In a company like this, you
don't really have inventory,
but certainly for older type
businesses, inventory can be a
key component of demand.
Cash flow warnings, and serial
acquisitions which we'll get
into all this.
TOM JACOBS: Hewlett-Packard.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: So Wall Street
wants earnings, and
they want revenues.
And so it's all about the
bottom line number.
One of the great things that
Google does, actually, is they
don't give Wall Street
guidance.
And so that means the analysts
actually have to do work.
They can't just plug it into
a model and come out with a
number that management gave
them, which works in your
favor if you're going to exceed
the expectations that
are out there.
But it's all driven
by expectations
for revenue and earnings.
So management's going to do
whatever it takes, by and
large, to keep the stock price
up, keep the stock options up,
protect their own job,
make everybody happy.
It's all driven by
expectations.
If you think about an income
statement, you have revenue on
the top and net income
on the bottom.
So the earnings that a company
reports are the least
important line item that
they ever talk about.
And why is that?
Because between revenue and net
income, you have-- this
pointer probably doesn't work
very well-- but you have lots
of line items that management
can utilize to derive whatever
net income they want.
So revenue is the
most important.
To the extent that I have
concerns about a company,
they're in direct proportion
to where they reside on the
income statement.
In an extreme case, if the
revenue for a company were
fictitious, which may be the
case with Autonomy, that
Hewlett Packard acquired--
we're really going to rag on
Hewlett-Packard today, I think--
then the entire financial model
would be fictitious.
So why does it matter what the
earnings are if the revenue is
not even real?
So when you're analyzing a
company, you want to look from
the top down.
The net income number is the
first line item on the
operating cash flow statement,
so when you analyze cash flow,
if the net income happens to be
manipulated, then cash flow
quality's probably
low as well.
But the vertical depiction of
an income statement really
kind of helps show the way that
we think about things.
So revenue related issues,
stuffing the channel.
Stuffing the channel is a way
of borrowing from the future
and pulling into the present.
So let's say it's September 28th
and there's two days to
go in the quarter.
And we'll pick on another
company, Oracle.
So Larry Ellison gets on a plane
and he flies all over
the place and he says, look, I
know you're in the pipeline
for December, but if you sign
the contract today I'm going
to give you 360 days to pay and
I'm going to give you 35%
off the list price.
And you say, wow,
that's great.
I got 360 days to pay.
That helps my cash flow.
I'm paying less off
the list price,
that improves my margins.
It certainly saves on other
expenses as well.
So all I care about is that it
gets implemented when you say
it's going to, and it
works out great.
The problem is, now I've stolen
you from December, and
I've pulled you into
September.
So now I've got to go to you and
say, I know you're in the
March quarter of next year, but
if you come on in, we'll
give you a big deal.
So you're kind of a mouse
on a treadmill.
Eventually, you run out--
TOM JACOBS: What it's really
like is, you borrow money--
I mean additional to that-- is
you borrow money from the
local loan shark at a high rate,
and then he wants his
money, so you go to the next
loan shark at a higher rate,
and eventually you're dead,
because that's how they take
care of you.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Eventually
you get both legs broken.
So it works until
it's doesn't.
An example of a company that I
wrote a research report on and
subsequently shorted--
actually it was the largest
short position ever in the
history of our fund,
AsiaInfo-Linkage--
TOM JACOBS: Holdings.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO:
AsiaInfo-Linkage.
Tom wrote this stuff.
TOM JACOBS: It's always
my fault.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: But basically
they're a telecom
provider in China and they have
what's called percentage
of completion accounting, which
means that they provide
software to a customer and then
they go implement it and
they get to decide--
management gets to decide how
much of that project is
actually done in a
given quarter.
So they estimate not only
the revenue, but also
the margin on it.
So you only know the
total revenue at
the end of a project.
If it's a $100 million deal, or
it's a $100 million deal.
The problem is, if I want to be
aggressive, I can recognize
90 million of it in one quarter
and then the other 10
million over let's say
three more quarters.
So you can front load the
revenue recognition.
Well, this is the only company
in the history of my career--
and I've probably looked
at 1,000 companies--
that over 100% of their growth
was coming from percentage of
completion accounting,
which is just--
I'm not a math whiz like you
guys, but I know enough with a
four function calculator that
you can't have over 100%
growth come from that factor.
And then you slap on top of it,
it's a Chinese company and
they have some question marks
with respect to their
corporate governance.
And put two and two together and
then this is what happens.
Stock price implodes.
This black line's about where
we got into it, 21.
It ended the year just
under nine bucks.
Day sales outstanding
is what I just
explained with Larry Ellison.
It gives you big terms.
This is Deckers.
What Deckers did was--
they make Ugg boots,
the sheepskin boots--
they extended payment terms to
their customers, basically
incentivize them to go take on a
bunch of inventory that they
didn't need in order to get it
off of Deckers balance sheet
and the stock, which
went from being a
growth darling, imploded.
Another one of our big short
positions earlier this year.
Aggressive inventory
management.
Companies have raw materials,
work in
process, finished goods.
Green Mountain Coffee
Roasters--
which was up big today on the
announcement of a new chief
executive officer--
has huge inventory issues, where
they've been building up
the coffee machines and the
actual K-Cups themselves.
If changing a CEO would really
help a company, then
Hewlett-Packard would be
in better shape than
they are right now.
So we see that Green Mountain
has also imploded.
It's up a little
bit from here.
But we actually think that
they're going to have to
write-down the acquisitions that
they made recently, as
well as potentially write
off some of that K-Cup
inventories.
These are K-Cups, by the way.
I don't know if you guys
use them here.
But these are stockpiling up at
your local Albertson's, so
if you want a discount, you can
just go over there and get
them at 50% off.
Cash flow warnings.
If the receivables and the
inventories and the payables
are all moving in the wrong
direction, it can show you
that the cash flow is actually
not coming into the business.
So revenue and earnings are
important, but cash actually
coming in is important.
You guys like to get paid
in cash, not K-Cups.
TOM JACOBS: Just one second,
on that, John.
Familiar with Rambus, which is
a Silicon Valley company?
I thought maybe.
For years, everybody thought
they had this great IP and
they were going to win all these
cases and that they had
all this cash flow and so on.
And actually, there was a period
of five years where the
only operating cash flow that
they produced was from adding
back stocked-based
compensation.
So actually, they weren't an
IP company, they were an
options giving company.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Until that ran
out, as we know, and then
the stock price imploded.
WMS Industries is a company
that makes slot
machines in Las Vegas.
And they were offering huge
incentives to their customers
to take on inventory in
order to get it off of
WMS's balance sheet.
They did a lot of that
channel stuffing.
It was reflected in the
cash flow statement.
And this was actually the first
stock I recommended to
the Motley Fool when I came
back to the company.
At about $39, it went to 48,
everybody screamed and yelled
at me, and now it's at 20.
And, by the way, when I
recommend these to go down,
that's what I'm recommending--
to go down, not up.
Serial acquisitions.
Oh, Hewlett-Packard.
Have we talked about
[INAUDIBLE]?
TOM JACOBS: Gosh, I forgot
that company somehow.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: When a
company's really going
sideways, they make a
lot of acquisitions.
It covers up weak cash flow.
You can stuff a lot of stuff
on the balance sheet--
expenses.
So you can basically understate
your expenses and
overstate your profits
by moving it on
to the balance sheet.
You can assign a lot of the
value of something to
goodwill, like a company
like Autonomy, which is
potentially a fraud.
Palm, for instance, which was a
big write-down, about a $1.2
billion write-down.
I think they wrote down
$9 billion of EDS.
So a total disaster.
Cisco Systems has been a heavy
acquirer for years.
They used to do it under the old
rules, called pooling of
interests, which is when you
merge two companies together.
That no longer exists.
Everything is what's called
purchase accounting.
So that has the ability to
really obscure the financial
statements.
So you want to look at companies
and whether or not
they're making serial
acquisitions.
They really get hammered in bear
markets when access to
capital gets shut off and you
can no longer finance it with
debt, or your equity is worth
a lot less because the stock
market is going down.
And now we're up to Tom and
buying on the fire sale.
Oh.
He's asking what happens when
the company goes public--
so on their initial public
offering, and they're flush
with cash, and then they
make acquisitions.
It actually still obscures the
financial statements, because
the way the purchase accounting
works is from the
day they make the acquisition
forward, it's two combined
companies, not ever
looking back.
So if I have $100 in revenue and
you have $10 in revenue, I
can make it look like
10% growth, even
though nothing changed.
Under poolings of interest,
which is what Cisco, when they
were really growing, was doing,
it actually made the
company look like they were
combined entities all the way
back into history.
So even if I'm flush with cash,
I can still obscure the
revenue growth, I can obscure
my cash flow.
I can do all kinds of
shenanigans on the balance
sheet to move expenses off
there, to create all kinds of
goodwill that doesn't
really exist.
And all that's just leading to
is big write-downs in the
future, and ultimately
that's reflected in
a poor stock price.
It doesn't really hit you until
like a bear market, when
you can't make the next big
acquisition, because the
equity markets or the debt
markets aren't available to
finance it.
TOM JACOBS: Think about
it as each time you
have another child.
You're a different company.
Your expenses are different.
You can't compare what it was
like last year, when you only
had six kids.
Now you have seven,
or one and two.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: I've never
thought about it
that way, but OK.
TOM JACOBS: No.
But you see, so your budget--
if you're doing year-over-year
budgeting, it's
not apples to apples.
So what a Hewlett-Packard does
is they just keep buying every
year, buying every year, so
you can never see what the
family is really doing.
They're like Bach's family.
What'd he have, 23 kids?
All right.
You can move to the
side now, John.
Just kidding.
I've talked about behavioral
finance already, and how that
changed the viewpoint.
Of course, Benjamin Graham
didn't need to know behavioral
finance in the '30s after his
brother-in-law had to bail him
out after the market crash.
Nothing worse than that, right--
having to depend on
your brother-in-law.
And then he resolved never to
lose money again, invented
Modern Value Investing, taught
Buffett at Columbia, gave him
his only A+, gave him
his first job.
And then Buffet went on to very
great things, of course,
and Graham continued
his adultery.
OK.
This is very simple, and there's
so many books written
on value investing.
It's one of the reasons
I'm last.
And very few, on this.
And ours, of course, is the best
because we don't give you
a college textbook.
We pick the top predictors that
John has seen over time.
I do all that work before I even
get to the value side.
I don't even look at a stock
until I've done the Earnings
Quality Analysis.
This is Graham's Mr. Market.
This is your business partner
who, when everything is great,
wants to pay you any price for
your half of the business.
That's when you want to sell.
This is Mr. Market when
everything's awful, and things
are going to get worse, and
never going to get any better,
and please take my shares for
whatever price you want.
This is when you get to buy
dollars for pennies and then
sell them for more than
they're worth.
Tweedy, Browne did a study
of many decades--
50 studies they looked at
of what actually works.
They found five characteristics.
And I'll go through
each of these.
The first is you want
to buy an asset for
less than it's worth.
And this happens because
of emotional markets.
You get the chance.
Efficient Markets Theory, that
many of us learned in finance
or MBA school, is
just no longer--
these poor Chicago Nobelists are
now reduced to writing in
The Economist ad hominem attacks
on the behavioral
finance people because
they can't
think of anything [? of ?]
[? facts ?] to refute it with.
It was very sad to see Lucas,
a great, great mind, writing
in the back of The Economist
and addressing no facts.
I like tangibles.
I like things I can
hold on to because
they're easier to value.
It does not mean they
lose value.
A building with cash flows, gold
in the ground, silver in
the ground, oil, gas.
I like things I can taste,
touch, feel, smell.
I don't own Google.
If I did own a tech stock--
whatever that means, anymore--
if I owned one with
intellectual property, this
is the one I would own.
And that's not just because
I'm trying to suck up.
But--
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: He's
good at that.
TOM JACOBS: But I have
this friend.
I've known him since
we were 16.
And he's always been just
this incredible genius.
He talks like this.
And probably there are a few at
Google who are like this--
very smart people that kind
of talk like this.
And he is now a muckety-muck
professor at Case Western.
Senior, just got a great
job, basically
given all this money.
Make this the best engineering
school in the country.
They got a huge amount
of money.
And as I was telling Alex at
lunch, I went to see him, we
had a friend's reunion
in August.
And he told me, Tom, I just want
to explain why you need
an Android phone.
OK?
I just want to explain to you
why Google is great and Apple
is now as evil as Microsoft.
And he showed me the amount of
data he is processing all
around the world all day long.
He's testing solar panels,
it's all amazing.
Free Google software.
He is using something
probably some of you
made, and it's free.
And he could not do his
job without it.
So all these companies that
he's testing whether these
solar panels will really
last 20 years or
not, free Google software.
That's all it took.
I was done.
I can't value a Facebook.
I don't know if it will
become like Myspace.
I think the advertising
model is a great one.
I was just never very
good at intangibles.
Tangibles, they have prices.
They're quoted every day.
Commodities.
Rents for commercial
buildings.
All right.
I think I've beaten that
horse to death.
Low multiple of cash flow.
Now, Tweedy, Browne used P/E,
and that's because for decades
and decades and decades, the
price to earnings ratio was
all you had.
In fact, it was only in the late
1960s that companies were
required to report the cash
flow statement at all.
Value investors love the balance
sheet and the cash
flow statement.
And part of the reason, as John
has demonstrated, the
income statement is not the only
one, but a large place
where the shenanigans--
or chicanery, as we say--
take place.
So I'm looking for low
enterprise value or market cap
to free cash flow.
How much actual cash is the
company throwing out?
Now, it can be a trap.
Bridgepoint Education is one
of these not for profit
education companies and selling,
basically, for a
dollar more than net cash per
share on its balance sheet.
You'd think it would be
something I would love-- buy a
cheap asset.
But it's intangible.
It's not buildings.
It's whatever brand they have
that can get students to get
government loans, to pay for
courses, and maybe not get
jobs because the industry is
very much in its infancy.
So you would think
someone like me
would buy it down here--
price, of course, is not a
reflection of valuation, but
in this case, it's very
close to net cash.
I'm buying an asset for
a very low price.
I have cash protection.
But I really don't know what th
asset is worth, so I can't
say am I getting it for 50
cents on the dollar?
That's called a value trap,
where value investors will get
all excited about it and
nothing happens.
Why do we care about low
price to assets and low
price to cash flow?
If it gets low enough, and the
business is at least steady
state, someone will buy you.
Guaranteed.
Or someone will come in and
say, you're running your
business terribly, it's
reflected in your valuation.
I'll buy up a lot
of your stock.
Carl Icahn, Bill Ackman, and
some other names that are not
household names.
They'll buy up a lot of stock
and agitate for you to spin
off a business.
Berkshire Hathaway gets what's
called a conglomerate discount
because we know he will never
sell off businesses.
If he did spin off businesses
and you owned Berkshire today,
your stocks all together,
after he spun off the
businesses in the public
markets, would be worth more.
So we say it's a conglomerate
discount when you don't think
they're going to spin
off businesses.
You're never going
to realize that.
So [? activist ?]
shareholders will come in and
try to create value through
catalysts to realize value,
such as spinoffs and
mergers and so on.
By the way, everybody thinks
that their merger is going to
be like Lake Wobegon.
85% of them don't add
shareholder value.
15% do, according to a study
at Harvard, but everybody
thinks their acquisition
will be above average.
Share repurchases.
Tweedy, Browne looks at insider
buying in their five
points of what works
in investing.
I would say that most insiders
of companies are no better
investors than the average
investor-- a lot of them.
Now, they do know stuff.
They do know that things are
coming down the pike, but, of
course, they're prevented for
acting on a lot of information
in certain legal
circumstances.
So I prefer to see share
[INAUDIBLE] purchases that are
bought when the valuation
is cheap.
When I would buy the stock
because it's selling for a
discount to assets, that's when
I want the company buying
back stock.
I want them buying back stock
when that investment--
when the stock value is so much
below its real worth due
emotion, due to the Mr. market
we saw, fear that that's a
better investment.
Buying back to the stock
at a discount.
It's like me or you buying the
stock at a discount than
wasting it on acquisitions
that destroy value.
I've never owned Berkshire
Hathaway.
I would today, because they now
have an absolute policy.
They buy back stock whenever
it's 110% of book value,
shareholder equity, or less.
Automatic.
Down to where their cash
is $20 billion.
They have a lot more
than $20 billion.
So that that's like a support
under the stock.
Every time it gets to a certain
low value, they whoosh
in, they buy it.
It's protection.
The fourth point is a large
decline in stock price due to
emotional reaction.
That's because stock prices tend
to revert to the mean,
which is why paying up for a
hypergrowth stock almost
always ends up in paying.
What goes up must come down.
What goes down comes back up.
Now, obviously, not in
the case of Google.
All right.
AUDIENCE: But I'm guessing
in the case of Apple, so.
TOM JACOBS: Yeah.
But in the case of
Apple, right?
Now, I apologize in advance
for choosing the
Macondo in the Gulf.
It's obviously a horrible
tragedy for the people on it,
for people who depended
on the Gulf, for the
environment of the Gulf.
However, I think that by
choosing something like this,
something so extreme, it's
useful to make a point.
So I apologize in advance for
saying you could make money in
this kind of environment.
But I think that it shows
you that in far lesser
circumstances, you
can, as well.
So this is an emotional event
that will cause assets to sell
at less than their real
value because
everybody throws it out.
They're scared to
death, right?
So that blue arrow is
Ensco, a driller--
an oil rig owner and driller.
They rent themselves out,
these big, huge
semi-submersible and drill
3,000, 12,000, 10,000 feet
below the ocean for oil.
And which--
oh, gosh.
I'm sort of in your way.
And which produce
where the oil's
coming from today, really.
So Macondo happens.
Transocean's Deep Horizon
rig blows up.
All the drillers go down,
every single one.
BP crashes, Transocean
crashes--
all the drillers you
can imagine.
Which, of course, at the
particular moment, being in
front of you, I can't
summon up.
But I know what I did.
That weekend, I went home and
I looked at all the drillers
and I said, this is a time to
look for a company that has
little to no exposure to the
Gulf, has an excellent safety
record, but yet has been
hit like all of them--
has a great balance sheet.
And Ensco was the
one I picked.
Eventually, you had reversion
to the mean.
When the fear was over, I
happened to sell not at the
top-- you never buy at the
bottom or sell at the top--
but we made some good money for
special ops members at the
Motley Fool.
I think that others
did better.
If you bought BP, it may
have done better.
If you bought Transocean, you
definitely did better.
But why didn't I buy it?
Because I couldn't value the
asset because the liability
was unknown.
We didn't know how much
they were going to end
up having to pay.
It was a big unknown.
With Ensco, I can see
the contracts.
They have them on their
site-- where all the
rigs are and so on.
All right.
Small market cap is
a key element.
Small companies, there's less
information about them.
So if you do the work,
you can uncover gems.
However, they tend to be more
volatile because they have
less volume.
So here's one of my favorites,
because it was a success.
We all had failures, but this
one has worked out well.
But just a little bit
of volume there--
that's what I guess [? they ?]
[? call ?] gapping up.
It just zoomed up when the
Mexican Tax Authorities gave
them a favorable ruling on
treatment of silver taxation,
giving them another $20
to $40 million a year.
When you're a $200 million
market cap company, $20 to $40
million is a lot of dough.
However, it's been
very volatile--
overreacted, now, coming
back down.
So what happens, though, is that
the more money you have,
the fewer small caps
you can buy.
Buffett--
it was $43 billion in cash.
Do you think the $240 million
Primero Mining matters to him?
It doesn't even--
cliche alert--
move the needle.
So, as all these guys--
the great Yale University
endowment manager, David
Swensen, and many say, size
is the enemy of returns.
It decreases the universe
of stocks you can buy.
If small caps provide the best
returns over time, provided
you apply all of the strategies
I'm pointing out
from Tweedy, Browne, you
all end up like rats
in a large cap cage.
All these big companies--
they're looking at
the same ones.
They're trying to find if
your $1, undervalued,
or Microsoft, $2--
it's all the same companies.
And it's really hard to
make money that way.
So what do you do?
The more money you have--
which would be a nice problem
for a lot of us, to have a
billion or something--
you look for activists,
you look for
catalysts, and large caps.
These will be people like Ackman
at JC Penney, who has
control of General Growth
Properties, which he was
scooping up at $0.50
which is $19.
Carl Icahn is now doing
this in natural gas
at Chesapeake Energy.
I'm a big natural
gas contrarian.
And, of course, in this, to
succeed, you have to be
contrarian.
Now, whether that will play
out, I don't know.
And then other catalysts
that unlock value.
They can happen with big
companies, but it takes
somebody to get in there,
get on the board,
and make stuff happen.
That summarizes that section,
and if we still have time,
John will give a--
[?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: I think
we're good ?]
for five minutes.
TOM JACOBS: --view of
market conditions.
We'll have a couple funny slides
at the end and we'll
take questions.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
As a short sale, I'll try not
to be too depressive about
where we're about to head into,
but I'll do my best to
[INAUDIBLE].
TOM JACOBS: We are from
Rochester and
Syracuse, we said.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: So we'll try
to end on a positive note.
As I mentioned earlier,
average investors or
individual investors are not
very good at asset allocating.
Well, neither are professional
investors.
And it's probably going to be
hard to see with this pointer,
so I'm just going to
use my fingers.
And this, again, is the low in
2009, and their average equity
allocation was about
0% stocks.
So they're telling you not to
own any stocks at the exact
crisis low.
This was when the US debt got
downgraded by Standard &
Poor's and everybody was jumping
out of buildings--
this was about September,
October, 2011.
TOM JACOBS: Well,
not everybody.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: I wasn't.
0% equities.
And then in March of this
year, they were at 75%
equities, which generally, when
they get that aggressive
on the bullish side, the average
returns are negative
7.7%, and that's right before
the market had a
reasonable pull back.
So right now, active investment
managers are fully invested.
So that's a contrary
indicator.
TOM JACOBS: As contrarian as the
individuals that we saw.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Right.
This is what's called the
Shiller P/E. This is like the
long-term smooth price to
earnings ratio on the market.
It's at, essentially, 24.
A bull market's never started
when the Shiller
P/E has been 24.
This has an implied negative
return of about 2% annualized
to where it is right now.
In my opinion, the
E is overstated--
TOM JACOBS: John, and negative
2% annualized, like,
[INAUDIBLE]
like 10 years out, or?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: No.
Over the next 12 months.
TOM JACOBS: Oh, OK.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: And so,
in my opinion, the E is
overstated--
that's the earnings-- because
profit margins are at all-time
highs in the United States, and
they're mean reverting.
So, for instance, if you guys
had a profitable project,
chances are some sort of
competition will come in and
at least try to squeeze that
down a little bit.
In the case of corporate profits
across the United
States of America, they're
at unsustainable highs.
So if profit margins mean
revert, like they've always
done since the history of
the world, then the E
is going to go down.
If price stays the same, then
the P/E ratio [? will get ?]
[? higher. ?]
TOM JACOBS: So, John, so
we're looking more
at this than that.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
This is the volume
of the market.
Stocks--
most people like to
think that they're
investors for the long-term.
The average stock is held for 21
seconds today, to put that
in perspective.
A lot of that's driven by
machines, of course--
computerized trading.
But stocks are just like
milk or gas or clothes.
They're a commodity,
like anything else.
Supply and demand drives
the price.
So this is the secular bull
market from 1982 all the way
up to 2000, 2001, before
the internet debacle.
If you notice, volume basically
trended with it.
It was going up as the stock
market was going up.
What you have now, though, is
the stock market's going up
and the volume is actually
going down.
And what didn't exist back here,
even in 2000, is what's
called high frequency trading.
These are these computer
machines that
just trade very rapidly.
In the last five years, the
volume of high frequency
trading is up about 700%,
but the profits are down
to about one sixth.
So they're squeezing
less and less lemon
juice out of the lemon.
If you were to remove
that, then, there's
nobody in the market.
There's really no buyers right
now, other than maybe Ben
Bernanke and the government.
But if we were to have
a reasonable--
TOM JACOBS: No politics.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: If we were
to have a reasonable
correction--
say 15%--
there's really nobody
underneath
here to support prices.
I went to the New York Stock
Exchange on the floor about
two years ago, and I was shocked
to see that there's
nobody around anymore.
They're basically reading the
New York Post and playing
cards on their iPads.
And what, in the old days,
happened was there was a
specialist, someone who's
responsible for a stock, and
that person's job was, if that
stock was crashing, to step in
and buy it and to protect the
integrity of the markets and
the shareholders.
But that's no longer
really the case.
So this is a very dangerous
trend, and this applies about
2% positive returns right now,
where we are, annualized.
This is the scariest chart of
all, but I said I was going to
end on a good note.
This is what happens in
secular bear markets.
Secular bear markets are
long-term bear markets, like
what happened from
2000 to today.
The stock market's flat.
A secular bull market
is from '82 to 2000.
And then within those big
picture markets, you have
cyclical bears and cyclical
bulls that last maybe three or
four years.
The average duration
of a cyclical
bull market's 39 months.
This is going back decades to
the start of maybe 1900s.
We're now 44 months into it.
So the next cyclical bear within
a secular bear is going
to be nasty.
That's where you're going to
want to put a little bit of
cash in a can somewhere
in the backyard.
Because here's what
happened during--
this is the Dow Jones
Industrial Average.
TOM JACOBS: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: These are the
best companies in America.
These are the ones--
aside from Google.
These are the ones that have
solid cash flows, they're
multinational, they probably
generate more than 50% of
their revenues outside
the country.
They can pay dividends,
yada, yada, yada.
These aren't companies
that are one
product, one trick ponies.
So the cyclical bear markets
within the secular bear are
negative 29.7, negative
31.5, negative 53.8,
and negative 16.8.
So if those are the best
companies, the best position,
or the best balance sheets, what
do you think is going to
happen to all the companies
underneath that that don't
have the financial stability
that the best ones do?
Well, on average, according to
William O'Neil, they go down
about two times the
average index.
So on a 31% decline here, you
could see a lot of small caps
go down 65%, 70%.
But since I said I would end
on a good note, other than
buying Google stock,
what can you do?
You could buy dividend growers
and initiators.
Since 1972, they've gone
up by 9.5% annually.
The S&P 500 on an
equal weighted
basis, has gone up 7%.
And for all you math whizzes out
there, you know that 2.5%
compounded annually over 40
years is a big difference in
how much money you're going to
end up at the end of the day.
All dividend payers are
about 8.7%, and then
here's the one to avoid.
The non-dividend payers, in
the S&P 500, have grown at
1.5% compounded annually
over the last 40 years.
So that's not even the
rate of inflation.
So if you want some protection,
you could buy a
short fund, like what I do.
You could go into Tom's domain,
which is small cap
value, or you could pay
attention to dividends and buy
a large cap dividend company--
the Johnson & Johnson's are
still going to be making
Band-Aids when you
and I are long gone.
TOM JACOBS: And which is 5%
dividend right now, which is
unheard of, for them.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
Huge yields.
So, Tom, you finish
it up here.
TOM JACOBS: All right.
So I'll take it out,
as they say.
So we obviously think that
a long-short portfolio
is the way to go.
Use earning quality analysis to
avoid sell or short stocks
that have the top predictors
of poor performance ahead.
And then we buy stocks offering
value with catalysts.
When we talked about small and
how small gets hit in these
situations, that's also when
you keep buying, right?
There's a lot of volatility
with small.
It doesn't mean they're bad, you
just have to have a longer
time frame, and when your shorts
come in, you take those
profits and put them
into the things
that have been hammered.
The idea is you'll
go from this--
you can all see the book's
upside down, right?
To this.
And then perhaps you'll even be
in a position to where it's
sunset in La Brea in LA,
you'll see this.
Thank you very much.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: That is our
billboard, by the way, by the
Hollywood Walk of Fame.
[INAUDIBLE].
TOM JACOBS: Yeah.
That's not like a Photoshop.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: It's not
superimposed Photoshop.
TOM JACOBS: Questions?
Do we have time?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: I guess so.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I know you haven't said
anything about HP--
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
Never heard of it.
AUDIENCE: And you also
recommend not
buying large cap stocks.
And HP's not--
at least not yet--
a large cap.
But I was wondering--
TOM JACOBS: Oh, it's
a large cap.
AUDIENCE: I know.
I know.
TOM JACOBS: Oh, you're kidding.
Sorry.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Seemed
to be a small cap.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
small cap.
So the question is, as value
investors, is that a good
investment now in '11?
TOM JACOBS: What,
Hewlett-Packard?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: No.
I wouldn't buy it with
counterfeit money.
TOM JACOBS: No.
And the reason for
that is simple.
The balance sheet is terrible.
So when you're looking
at value--
and I don't know.
What do they have?
Tangible, intangible.
They have massive
amounts of debt.
In fact, I write this section
in the book, after John said
write Hewlett-Packard.
Massive amounts of debt, and
they're still paying a
dividend and buying back shares,
and they're writing
down the value of acquisitions
all the time.
This is not a value stock.
Alex, you were saying that it
was written that all these top
value guys have been killed
in this stock.
I agree with John.
I wouldn't touch it.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: They do
a lot of what's called
recurring, non-recurring
charges, so they take a charge
every quarter, but it's
non-recurring, but then it
happens over and over again.
I would wait until all that's
been flushed out and they've
pretty much written everything
off their balance sheet.
And then once they've thrown in
the kitchen sink, then you
could sit back, analyze it, and
look and see if they have
assets that are worth more
than whatever the
[? shared asset is. ?]
TOM JACOBS: Right now, you
just don't know what
really is going on.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: It's kind
of hard to decipher.
TOM JACOBS: All right.
She asked what asset classes
are attractive today.
Gold, she said, was
at a high price.
The stock's at a high price.
And I'm sure John
has something--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
high price.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah,
I'm actually a
pretty big gold bull.
I've been a gold bull for the
most part of the secular bull
market in gold, and generally,
the secular bear markets in
stocks-- like that second to
last chart that I showed--
they don't end until gold is
about one to one or two to one
on the Dow Jones Industrial
Average.
So that means either the Dow's
going to 5,000 and gold's
going to 2,500, or if the
Dow stays at 10,000,
gold's going to 5,000.
And to put that in perspective,
it started at 34
to 1 in 2000, 2001 when gold
started to take off.
So I think gold has a--
TOM JACOBS: 32 what to--
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: The Dow Jones
Industrial Average--
TOM JACOBS: Was 34 times gold?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: --was 34
times the price of gold.
And now it's about
eight to one.
But eventually, that spread
will narrow before you get
into the next bull
market in stocks.
I'm still bullish on gold.
In terms of yield, that's a
tricky one, because we've been
in a 30-year bull market
for bonds as well.
I believe it's the first time
that bonds have outperformed
stocks over a 30-year period.
I like some certain
high yield bonds.
There's a fund that
we know of--
TOM JACOBS: Oh, we love it.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: [INAUDIBLE]
called HYLD.
It's the Peritus High
Yield Fund.
TOM JACOBS: That's
the ticker, HYLD.
That's not a recommendation.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: That's not a
recommendation, but they're
very good at picking certain
high yield bonds.
Otherwise, it's very tough to
find yield in a zero interest
rate environment [INAUDIBLE].
TOM JACOBS: John, if
I could just add.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Absolutely.
TOM JACOBS: Part of the reason
that we also are very
interested in HYLD is that
it's led by a guy who's a
value investor in bonds.
And one of the things I didn't
pick on was jockeys.
If you know someone does
something really well in an
area you don't know anything
about, and the person has done
it over and over and over and
succeeded every time, that
jockey can ride any
horse and win.
And Tim Gramatovich at HYLD is
a value investor in bonds.
I know squat about investing
in bonds.
And he is really, really
good at it.
And he started with
Michael Milken.
He sat at the feet
of the masters.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So, nice
presentation.
But, to me, it was very
much a fairy tale.
The science, 70 years of
financial economics show
there's zero evidence that you
can pick stocks, zero evidence
you can time market.
And you mentioned that
behavioral economics is the
trend that's taken effect.
But really.
That's not the truth.
90% of economists still believe
that behavioral
economics is just--
[INAUDIBLE].
TOM JACOBS: So you would say
that because 90% of people
believe something, it's right?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm saying the
science does not support this.
TOM JACOBS: No, and, actually,
I would disagree entirely.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: And then
things like--
TOM JACOBS: So that's a
statement, actually.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
And then one thing that I saw
missing throughout the whole
thing is that, finance 101,
there's no free lunch.
You didn't mention the risk.
If value stocks have higher
historical expected returns,
it's because they're riskier
throughout riskier times.
Because when crisis hits,
because when everything's
going down, they go down more.
When you lose your job, your
investment's also down.
So that's why.
Because you're taking
higher risk for
higher expected return.
It's not like, OK, I'm investing
in this thing and
I'm making more money
than others.
TOM JACOBS: So what's
your question?
AUDIENCE: So I'm saying that all
these points were missing.
So--
TOM JACOBS: No.
What is missing, really?
I think you might be making
two fundamental mistakes.
One, that all the studies
show you can't
outperform the market.
I think that's a statement
that is just wrong.
Because there are studies that
do show that you can.
And when Tweedy, Browne set
out to do it, they read
everything, absolutely
everything--
every academic paper they could
get their hands on.
And what you do is you wait
until the market throws
something out, and if it's not
crazy, then you wait for it to
revert to the mean.
If value investing didn't
work, David Swensen--
I mean, everybody
says Buffett.
And everybody goes,
well, Buffett
had an unusual situation.
I can name you 30, 40, 50, 60
managers, 100 managers who
have done this.
Buffett's famous paper
in 1984 at Columbia,
he talks about this.
Now, when you say 90% of the
economists think something, I
generally think, well, it's
probably because they're
graduate students, in order to
get a job, have to do what
they say or they won't
get recommended.
And we all know that in fields
like psychology and
psychiatry, where cognitive
behavioral therapy is all the
rage, you can't get a job if you
do EMDR, which is now the
standard of care in the
military for PTSD.
So the world moves according
to what your particular
investment is.
If you're a Nobel economist,
you're not going
to say I was wrong.
But there must have been a
reason that a sociologist in
2002 was awarded this in
behavioral finance.
I would just say that we can
argue about this strongly, and
there are obviously many
points of view.
But I just can't accept that all
studies show that nobody--
blah, blah, blah.
I just-- that's [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
We could argue about it
all day, so we'll go
on to another question.
But I'll just say that I
started my career as a
quantitative analyst, working
with high powered computers
back then, and the market--
which is generally viewed as the
Standard & Poor's 500 is
market cap weighted,
so that in and
of itself is a strategy.
They just decided, which, right
now, is Apple, would be
number one.
That's the 31st percentile of
all strategies in terms of
performance from 1929 to 2007.
So there's billions and billions
of dollars that have
been made and are actually
managed on these quantitative
strategies that show that 69%
of the strategies that we
created actually outperform
the market.
So it's done in historical
testing and it's
done in real time.
Beyond that, I don't
really know--
I mean, we could sit here and
kind of slice it a million
different ways, so I'm just
going to go based on my
experience.
But.
Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: I just want to see if
I got your point correctly.
So you started with saying that
protect yourself from the
losers and [INAUDIBLE] by
looking at the sheets, right?
And then--
TOM JACOBS: Protect yourself
from losers and what?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: By looking at
the financial statements.
TOM JACOBS: Yes, right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM JACOBS: Right, yes.
AUDIENCE: And then you said at
the end that [INAUDIBLE]
is going to go down and
there's going to be
[INAUDIBLE] losers.
Isn't it a big opportunity
to make money?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
I'm a short seller, so that's
a big opportunity.
In 2008, which was the largest
crisis of our lifetimes, we
did very well.
We do very well in 2001
and 2002, as well.
But in a normal cycle, like 2004
to 2007, the market still
went up every year, but there
were pretty big opportunities
to find companies that were
going to blow up or
under-perform because the
volatility was very low and,
in general, expectations were
very high for the market.
Since 2009, the market's either
been straight up or
straight down because of the
central bank interventions
that are occurring.
If we get back to a more
normalized environment some
day, then paying attention to
these warning signs is going
to be really crucial, even
in an up market, as well.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
over 60% of stocks
under-perform the index.
So does that then mean if you
[INAUDIBLE] the index
[INAUDIBLE] individual stocks
have a better chance to
[INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: That's
a great question.
TOM JACOBS: What was
the question, then?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: So she asked
that nearly two thirds of the
companies actually under-perform
the index, so
why not [? be low on ?]
the index in
short individual companies?
That's exactly how we ran a
hedge fund for three years
before we launched our ETF.
We went [? low on ?] the index
and short our stocks.
I can't tell you what the
returns are, because I'm not
allowed to, but it is a
very viable strategy.
If you can pick individual
companies that are going to
fall by the wayside even when
the general trend of the
market is up, then you can
capture the spread between the
two and you've offset some of
the risk of just being short
or just being long.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So [? you wouldn't ?]
consider in
the [INAUDIBLE]
additional margin cost for the
[? short ?] positions?
TOM JACOBS: She asked, does
this also include the fact
that you're paying interest to
the broker who's lending you
the money for you to buy on
margin when you're short?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: The best, or
maybe the only way for an
individual investor to do it is
through interactive brokers.
They're the only ones that
really have enough inventory
of short positions available
to allow you to pursue that
kind of strategy, and they're
also the cheapest provider in
the marketplace, so the cost of
shorting most stocks, which
is general collateral, is
about 40 basis points.
That's what it would cost to--
AUDIENCE: IB, right?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: IB, yeah.
You can't do it through Schwab,
for instance, because
they don't offer enough
inventory of shares to be able
to short them.
It's just not their
business model.
Yes?
Well, we'll get him first
and then [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I just have a quick
question about short selling.
And this might be wrong, but
it's been my experience that
short movements oftentimes
happen quite rapidly, whereas
long movements happen
over time.
They can also happen rapidly,
but just in aggregate, they
[? happen ?] over time.
So as someone who can't be
involved in trading stocks
every day for eight hours a day,
or analyzing for eight
hours a day, what sort of
strategy might I have to
actually do short sales?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Well, you
could buy an ETF that has
individual short positions, but
this isn't a commercial.
TOM JACOBS: Oh, John's
not promoting--
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
You're right, though, because
people run for the exits
really fast, generally.
But there also are those kind
of secular declines.
I'll give you one that we
shorted, Research in Motion,
which we probably shorted
somewhere in the 50s or 60s,
and now it's in the
low single digits.
We got out of it way too early--
probably around $18,
is a rough guess--
but that's just been a long--
there's been a couple huge moves
down, but it's also been
kind of a long slope down.
And I believe it's Chapter 7 of
the book, we give you some
technical tools that you don't
have to watch intraday that
give you some warning signs to
show you that the stock is
already starting to break down
and could signal maybe now's
the time to get in there.
I don't think what you need
to be doing is looking at
intraday quotes and really
trying to time it on a real
short-term basis.
In fact, I don't even have
a quote machine.
I don't look at quotes at all
except for end-of-day quotes,
but never intraday.
So I think that when you have
a chance to peruse the book,
you'll see some strategies in
there that will allow you to
take a little bit of a longer
time frame and still be able
to pursue that approach.
You had a question, yes.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
with bigger large cap stocks
[INAUDIBLE].
I think most of the S&P 500
are paying dividend.
You have a threshold and then
you have to pay 2%--
TOM JACOBS: So this was a
question talking about large
cap dividend payers.
Is there a threshold
for the yield?
Is that what you're saying?
I would like to just address
that one of the issues,
unfortunately, with dividend
payers is that
it's not just yield.
Unfortunately, you really have
to look at what percentage of
revenues, free cash flow, and
income is getting paid out.
Because the last thing
you want is the
dividend to get cut.
For example, Shippers.
They have good times.
They pay 11% out, 12%.
That looks really great.
But Shippers, they pay
everything out as dividends
when times are good, and then
they cut it when it's down.
And it happens over and
over and over again.
So as a rule of thumb, you don't
want a company that's
paying out more than 50% of free
cash flow or net income.
So you do have to
actually look.
The other thing is, if they're
growing, it's more likely that
they will be able to increase
the dividend.
Fair enough?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: Yeah.
I was just offering that up as a
solution other than shorting
the market if we're getting
into another
cyclical bear market.
TOM JACOBS: That
is [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: But if you
look at-- and I believe this
goes through 2010--
from 1980ish, when Apple went
public, and compared it to
Philip Morris, which is pretty
much a sleepy cigarette
business that had multi-business
units.
Apple stock is up--
I'm making up the numbers now
because I don't have it in
front of me, but it's up like,
say, 7,500% or 10,000%, and
Philip Morris, with those
dividends and reinvested
dividends is up 20,000%.
In other words, the dividend
is a real key component to
long-term growth in
your portfolio.
And so you should at least think
about them when you're
going out there and picking
individual stocks.
TOM JACOBS: And i think that the
point also is protecting
yourself if we're going
to have a large drop.
I don't think it's like,
suddenly we're talking about
the long side of the portfolio
conforming to the points that
I made from the study.
It's something you might
consider facing the kind of
long-term, possibly negative
annualized returns that the
market is telling
us we'll have.
Now, to be fair to your question
in another way, the
answer easily is dollar-cost
averaging discipline.
That's really the response.
Because otherwise,
what do you do?
But that gets us back to
whether you can do it.
Some of you can do this.
I know people that can do that
in their discipline.
But what I didn't want to do at
the beginning was to have
any doubt that the academic
studies show most
people can't do that.
And that's where the
opportunities come in.
But if you can do that,
you can do that
and go home, basically.
But it's got to be consistent.
[?
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: We've got ?]
[? a-- ?]
[? Tom. ?]
AUDIENCE: So you're alluding
to the fact that you think
we're going to have another
one of these March, 2009
drops, and one thing you could
do is just say, well, I'm
going to go to cash in my
portfolio and wait for that to
happen, and then I'll buy
at the bottom and--
TOM JACOBS: Well, but you
never know when that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But one of the concerns that I
have with that is if you put
everything in cash, what happens
if all of a sudden the
dollar's worthless?
Do the attorneys decide that
the [INAUDIBLE] going to
become the world currency?
Your cash isn't
[? going to work ?] anymore.
It's just inflation drives
the cash of [INAUDIBLE]
until [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: That the
kind of adverse move will
probably happen fast.
First of all, it is
going to happen.
You're going to have
panics and crashes.
I don't know when it's
going to happen.
It could be the next year or
the year after, but you're
getting into an aged bull
market, was kind of my point.
You're beyond sort of
the normal duration.
The dollar will probably rally
in that environment, and the
reason why is that outside of
the United States, there's a
lot of short dollar trades that
are on by hedge funds,
for instance.
They've been using the dollar
as the funding currency for
their highly levered bets
because the interest rates on
the dollar are essentially
zero.
So it's not costing them
much, if anything, to
put that trade on.
So when the market tanks, they
have to meet redemptions,
because people are yanking
money out of their funds.
When they meet redemptions,
what do they have to do?
They have to raise cash.
How do they raise cash?
They unwind their
short position.
Where are they most short?
The dollar.
So the dollar actually spikes.
So if you look in 2008,
during a crisis, the
dollar actually spiked.
The dollar actually spiked
when the US debt got
downgraded last year.
Why?
Because people got nervous,
and every time they get
nervous, where do they go?
They go to the United States
and they repatriated their
short positions.
That won't always be the case.
I think you've got
a valid point
about the Chinese currency.
And then, actually, the Chinese
have removed, I
believe, 10% or 13% of their
treasury holdings this year,
so they're clearly shifting
away from that.
So the only reason why the
United States gets away with
everything that it can do
politically and we can get in
all this stuff is because
it has the reserve
currency in the world.
So as long as that's still the
case, I think you're OK with
going to cash.
When that's no longer the
case, then yeah, you
absolutely need to find
something else.
But go back to March
of '09 when 45% of
the AAII was in cash.
Would you have the gumption to
be able to go in there just
and just buy stock?
I mean, that's what you
have to ask yourself.
Only you can answer
that question.
TOM JACOBS: Well, and here's
how I dealt with it.
Because I'm valuing stocks all
the time according to cash
flow, according to net asset
value, after learning in 2000,
2002, when this started
happening in 2008, and I know
that small caps get hammered,
but they also bounce back
faster and higher.
Because when you sell and you're
liquid, it has more
effect on the stock price.
So [INAUDIBLE]
watching the portfolio go down
and down and down, and what I
do is I sell the higher valued
stuff, the higher
ratios, and buy lower.
And you just keep doing until
there's nothing left that's
more attractive, and you say,
well, I'm taking losses.
I'm taking losses.
Well, it was my rollover IRA.
But nevertheless, the studies
would show that the returns
from this outpace the
tax consequences.
It got to the point where
it was March 2009.
I had no idea it
was the bottom.
Nobody knows.
John actually has a pretty good
record with market timing
in certain situations,
but down to the day?
No.
Nobody has a clue.
I, in March 2009, had
nothing more to buy.
Everything I knew was
a buyout candidate.
And I just said, OK.
Some day this is going to
revert to the mean.
And so I was down a bunch in
2008 and up 70% in 2009.
But this is the volatility
issue.
It's why you can make
money in small cap.
Because people say to
me, well, Tom, I
didn't have any money.
Well, you always have money.
You just have to know what you
own, and then you switch out
of the less attractive, more
highly valued to the least
until there's nowhere
more to go.
Now, if you have the short side,
of course, the short
side is making you profits
that you can reinvest.
And so this is a very hard
concept to explain, and also
it's not something you
can just do in
10 minutes on Saturday.
We'll admit that.
MALE SPEAKER: Last
question, please.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO:
Last question.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So does the real
estate market have the same
kind of cycle as the
stock market?
TOM JACOBS: Residential
or commercial?
She's asking about the real
estate market, does it have
cycles like the stock market?
AUDIENCE: Maybe residential.
Because I kind of feel
like housing is
starting to pick up.
A lot of the stock market
has been higher and
higher for a while.
TOM JACOBS: The thing is, I
would never buy residential
homebuilder, ever.
And that probably means
there's a lot of
money I won't make.
Because real estate is only
worth the net present value of
the cash flows from it.
So really, your house is only
worth what you could rent it
for, discounted to today.
Well, how are you going to--
it's so crazy.
You've got to know the
difference between one street
in Palo Alto and one street in
Sunnyvale and I can't do that.
Now, with commercial real
estate, particularly with real
estate investment trusts, if
you know the capitalization
rate-- sorry for the jargon--
that the CEO was paying, if you
can see the prices being
paid, you can get an idea of
the value of that building
versus the cash that
it throws off.
I'll give you an example.
There's a Southern California
guy named Stuart Tanz who buys
strip malls.
He doesn't buy fancy Fashion
Valley in Irvine--
what's it called?
Fashion Island or something.
The big fancy mall
down in Irvine.
He goes to these neighborhood
strip malls anchored by a
supermarket, where there's no
competition, and somebody gave
him $400 million and
said, OK, Stuart.
Go out and buy these
in the crash.
And he knew all the players
because he's been doing this
for 40 years.
So all these people
were underwater.
They call him up.
These things aren't
even advertised.
And he's taking them for the
note that they owe the bank.
They just want to hand
over the keys.
And it's pretty hard to lose
money when you invest at that
point, because people in
neighborhoods, which don't
have other shopping options,
are going to go to the
supermarket.
He fixes the parking lot, puts
some trees up, puts a new coat
of paint on, has escalator
[? rents, ?] fills up the
empty spaces with anything.
I mean, not just nail salons
or tattoo parlors.
Just to make a little
joke there.
But I can see the cash flows
from that, and I can see the
distressed real estate.
That's one of my favorite,
favorite areas because I can
value the cash flows.
Residential, it's just too--
local, local, local.
JOHN DEL VECCHIO: All right.
Well, thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
TOM JACOBS: And we'll sign
the books, by the way.
Anyone who wants us to.
Thank you.